I am from Grand Rapids Michigan so not
too far from Hillsdale so in high school
I played football hockey and lacrosse
loved all three so I wasn't even sure in
high school that I wanted to pursue
football I guess more more than the
other sports it pursued me I've got a
great relationship with Coach Otterbein
kids during my time there and I believe
it's still the case today but he's the
running backs coach so as a running back
I spent a lot of time with Coach
Otterbein he knows a lot about football
he's had a lot of success at Hillsdale
College on top of that you know he holds
a Bible study every Friday morning in
his office that aspect of things really
drew me in I think part of the the fun
of being at Hillsdale is it was such a
small school and we were able to compete
with the larger schools and that was
something that we always cherished and
kind of had the chip on our shoulder to
knock off the you know the David versus
Goliath type it was a hard-working Bunch
the culture was definitely one of
winning when I came in there that tide
was turning a guest for Hillsdale
College my freshman year we made the
playoffs sophomore year we made the
playoffs junior year we didn't make the
playoffs but we actually won the GLIAC
which is you know funny how that works
it was a winning culture it was
competitive hard-working and that's both
on the field in the classroom success of
a running back depends on everyone else
essentially so I was fortunate enough to
play with great offensive lineman I was
fortunate to play with great
quarterbacks great receivers so you know
having all those other weapons at your
disposal on offense really opens things
up for running back the memory that
would stand out most to me from my time
at Hillsdale College was my junior year
when we were able to win the GLIAC
Conference championship to my knowledge
that hadn't been done in quite some time
we won the GLIAC on Saturday then we had
our team banquet on Sunday and remember
coach out of mind getting up to the
podium and just screaming in joy because
it was such a great accomplishment
something we were all very proud of
relatively quickly after graduation I
became engaged to my now wife Katie
Katie was my girlfriend junior and
senior year at Hillsdale College and she
was a loyal fan she would drive up from
Indiana University come to a few
a year I have a daughter that is six
months old which has been a game changer
in a good way our lives will never be
the same but we don't ever want it to be
the same because she's been such a
blessing to us we enjoy everyday with
her it's something new something
exciting for sure I guess a byproduct of
being on a great team is that individual
awards or induction such as this come
about so I'm humbled that I was one that
was chosen
[Music]